let's let's actually talk about what's
going on in with mr. jung jong hoon mr.
Jang
mr. master Kim Kim is the last I guess I
thought I don't know wait what really
think as a Korean I would understand how
names work yes don't you know no I do
know Kim is a very common last name
yeah can you Lee and park I think mm-hmm
well here's the story and pool kim
jeong-hoon truthers think he was
replaced by a body double but it's okay
everybody before I even get into this
for for the sake of YouTube's rules I
just want to make sure you all know that
CNN said it's not true and because
they're an authority of it they're an
authoritative source so it's confirmed
Kim jong-un is back but that being said
we're just gonna read this article
anyway and none of us really believe
it's a body double for a world leader I
mean it's not like other world leaders
have other ever had body doubles or
anything I mean oh wait what's this oh
wait oh have been many body doubles
leaders who actually had body doubles
Wow who's this guy dictators all I'm
general Bernard Montgomery and his
double m e clifton what cool
what a fantastic name Oh Saddam Hussein
definitely a body double anyway next to
them I'm not I actually think him
turning his back I think people
overreacted but I do think he probably
at a body double yeah yeah I just you
know what I think is they love playing
games the press they love lying and they
have every opportunity to you know try
and screw with us so you know maybe
maybe he's gotta bite up buddy double
doesn't mean he's dead or anything like
that so I don't know for sure what do
you think he was just trolling the world
right now like well actually make
everyone think that I died yeah yeah and
you put my sister on everyone everyone
now knows who is sister us maybe
exactly yep she but she was nobody she
she actually avoided the press until
three months ago was that for her first
appearance alright so maybe unless he
died a long time ago yeah I know I check
us out so there's some photo is
interesting The Daily Dot says Kim
jong-un truthers think he was replaced
by a body double and they gonna tell you
know basically say what everyone's
already said so TMZ reported his death
and then eventually the reporting
changed and the reporting like of
actually the story is I think this is an
actual headline it said kim jeong-hoon
is either dead incapacitated or totally
fine okay great reporting everything but
I guess I guess you can be in between
totally fine and incapacitated yeah like
feeling unwell I mean technically that
is probably the truest news article yeah
life exists news 11 so here's here's
what they show we have these tweets um
look at these photos lewis mensch says
don't know don't care
see no reason to alter my earlier stance
these aren't the same men you know what
I love about these photos hmm is that
there was a similar story about Hillary
Clinton okay not that long ago because
there was a photo of a woman that like
people were saying was not Hillary
Clinton and it really did look weird
okay like did not look like her no no
you know that photo right yeah you sent
it to me yeah and you're like who is
this no ice cream so there was a photo
of Bill Clinton and Hillary Clinton okay
and everybody thought it wasn't really
Hillary okay so I cropped out just the
woman and scented people saying who is
this woman
and most people told me I don't know all
right because I was like the Bill
Clinton next to her people did yeah oh
yeah Hillary but it was probably just an
awful picture of Hillary you know maybe
people understand how camera angles
change how you look true and it was like
a low up close like wide shot and I was
looking something I don't know maybe it
wasn't her I'm just saying like maybe
you actually got a glimpse of under her
mask oh I've heard the river and some
scales were coming around some reptilian
like a snake let's talk about the best
Korea's best Korea's so what they're
pointing out this person says the
chipped incisor is a definite giveaway
it's not kim jeong-hoon on the right you
see a photo of Kim jong-un and he's got
his teeth are pretty straight he's got
big ol incisors those look like great
teeth he had some work done oh dude you
know he's like a multi-millionaire he's
like ridiculously wealthy that makes it
yeah that's why he's fat sure then look
at this guy on the left his teeth are
very different like can you see this
yeah that left two bigger than the right
tooth so he was not only different
here's what I would normally say okay if
somebody said his chipped incisor my
response immediately goes sometimes
people chip their teeth that happens
didn't you hear Chris Cuomo chipped his
tooth shivering like oh I chipped my
tooth well there you go I don't actually
- that actually is they glued it back on
actually yeah you know one thing I have
about these kind of things is one of
these pictures from what what is you
know what what is this you know this
could be anything no this guy might not
even be North Korean he might just be
some random dude from the internet
they're like oh no this looks like him
this is the photo they released they
claimed was him
Oh North Korea so like this on the CNN
thing right yeah oh right yeah then cut
any crappy photos though they are right
so this is a this is a video this is the
one for a video from CNN where it says
Kim jong-un US unit images appear
legitimate according to a US official
images of kim jong hoon at a May Day
celebration appeared to be legitimate
this would be the leaders first public
appearance in about three weeks
oh wait a minute CNN is actually not
confirming he's back there just saying
it appears he's back no a UN ok a UN
yeah was it you I'm sorry a US official
not a you an official US official right
is saying that they appear to be
illegitimate okay up here right I don't
know okay these photos are really grainy
so I can't I can't say but why I don't
know Kim jong-il died why what's what's
the problem if he dies they'll just say
it's something point it's somebody else
what's the point why does he need to
live that he's young and maybe it's just
like a strategic time he's only like two
years older the three years older than
me he's 36 he's my age yeah never mind
he's and he's though he's the same age
as my annum and he's a world leader what
have you been doing with your life
that's right video games yeah why aren't
you the leader of best Korea well I
don't have an end like some people I
know
Tim so hold on there's there's more
photos you know what man look here's
another one it says look at these two
images and note the teeth
the first one is kim jeong-hoon a few
weeks ago the real one
the second is hey Jay you today as shown
by RT note the gap in the teeth and the
second image a body double I mean maybe
I'm sick and pull these pictures up make
him make him know that second image did
look a little different yeah those teeth
do not look the same yeah he has that's
a gap look at that now hold on hold on
hold on
wait a minute
yeah look there's no gas that's a Bettis
significant gap in his front so hold on
think about what this means if this is
true it means that in North Korea they
have a guy who's assigned communists job
is literally just keep eating to get fat
because nobody's fat in North Korea or
he probably just eats the exact same
foods they found a guy was the same
height
yeah and they sat him down and they were
like whatever Q eats you eat yep and so
he started I'm on the doing I'm allowed
to do that mom actually Korean and
Japanese by the way oh yeah you can I am
I'm actually doing an imitation of one
of my relatives good cuz I'm people
gonna complain anyway yeah they are yeah
yeah man so I I'm officially allowed to
imitate anyone Japanese and anyone
Korean nice no I actually I actually did
grow up eating a lot of Korean food my
mom would cook and stuff so uh so here's
another photo it says was the kim
jeong-hoon who cut the ribbon at the
fertilizer plant a body double or nah
nah so they have more photos now
actually look at this I know this is
weird stuff man I got I got to admit
let's not let's let's stop playing games
yeah I I mean yeah it look like
different people it looks like a hair do
I look at the way I was wearing a wig
that is not the same dude I feel about
that maybe oh you know what else I
wanted to say before like maybe he's
just eating getting fatter but that
looks like a wig man it does look at
that it looks like they have some guy
who just does not that's creepy so
different look at the teeth I'll tell
you what drastically is rates what we're
saying is okay we're not gonna get
banned for entertainments conspiracy
theory for two it's a conspiracy theory
there's one reason though why just
because the people pushing it like Louis
Mensch and like Akilah Hughes they're
lefty oh they're saying it we're good
we're good
yeah so if YouTube has a problem we'll
just be like oh no that's like a
left-wing thing look oh that's right
little man okay hey left-wing stuff
that's fine
yeah only conspiracy theories from Alex
Jones ARB Anibal yeah when when when
when Akilah Hughes and Lewis men screech
about Russia for three years or whatever
well not a key lime I tried drag her
she's talking about Kim jong-un which I
don't actually disagree with but Lewis
matches famous for saying like for years
like we have
that Trump she I think she accused
Cassandra of being a Russian agent
serious links it's like dude that's
ridiculous I'm not under four years but
yeah so we're good we're good we're all
good but it is true that body doubles
exist man so this is the crazy thing to
me is why is it so taboo to entertain
the possibility that kim jungeun has a
body double yes totally believe it you
know what I think you know what I think
maybe he's not dead maybe he's just on
vacation incapacitated no no maybe he's
on vacation he's like chilling summer
he's like you know what a month though
you be me for a little bit yeah I need
to chill people are starting to get
worried that you're gone I'm playing GTA
man GTL oh no write that online have him
do it you know it's funny is that
apparently I've heard he does play video
games online seriously yeah I wonder
what games you play I wonder what
consoles I think you wouldn't even know
you're playing against Kim jong-eun hmm
yeah I heard he was big into video games
cuz I don't know where he didn't go to
school in like Switzerland or Sweden or
something Switzerland maybe was it yeah
thanks whistling yeah Switzerland I
think that's it so yeah he probably
plays I heard he plays a bunch of like
online FPS games I don't know if that's
true or not but they're a bunch of
really famous people play games you
probably even realize you're playing
with cool yeah could you imagine playing
like a game against Kim jong-un and he
isn't he's just like sitting there like
I don't know what they eat for snacks in
North Korea do they have snacks
now that dude's got I mean Burger King
overnighted to him whenever he wants
Stalin of course had a body double
didn't Stalin have more than one Oh
Felix date dad ev the day of I don't
really look I am I don't know
no but he looks like him but it doesn't
even know dude it doesn't even matter
because you get you get a guy who looks
somewhat like him if people gonna be
like that's him yeah that's it well
nowadays you got to be really good with
it because like back when it was Stalin
it was like there was no social media
like we've got today like no one really
like you saw his picture once and if
this other dude showed up and was like
doing a speech you wouldn't know right
you wouldn't know you never really met
Stalin in real life have you ever met a
celebrity like seen a library like
walking on the street mm-hmm a lot of
people don't realize this like they
don't look the same yep because when
when you know I remember being told this
when I was
because my family owned a cafe and some
like well-known people had had walked in
to the cafe before and they look
different mm-hmm and my parents were
like it's because when they film movies
they go for the best angles all the time
and they'll shoot like four or five
different ways yeah and so the way you
see somebody is not how they actually
are well sometimes they look exactly the
same
sometimes you know Giselle you know
Giselle famous female model bündchen
yeah yeah
so I did a job with her once she looks
exactly the same in real life Wow like I
was like oh I know exactly who you are
you look exactly the same what happened
there you go
in I can't remove a movie I was watching
it was in Tom Cruise movie and Tom
Cruise I think is well like five seven
yeah is it oh that's taller that I
thought he was yes five seven he was he
was walking in front of someone who I
know was a lot taller than an actor okay
and they were the same height because
these angles yeah liked because they
want him to look tall and tougher what I
recommend what movie it was but almost
every movie he's ever been in right
probably yeah he's actually yeah he's
relatively short dude so I've seen
people on the street and I didn't take
took a few minutes and I'm like was it
no that couldn't have been I don't know
was it and then all of sudden me were
friends like dude that really was you
know someone someone like Wow takes you
awhile you know imagine you've seen
photos and videos of someone like Kim
jong-un and then a dude shows up was a
big fat Korean guy with a slicked back
hair you probably like looks like him to
me I don't know it's also also think
about this too like with these photos
let me find one of the weirdest looking
photos like no no he's kind of weird
everything not this one let me do the
other one yes right here yeah this one
the eyebrows are different the hairline
looks fake totally does wait wait look
at the side of the head - yeah that is
not and look at his ears the ears
there's a different that your stick out
way more on the left
I mean he could have just here's my
point but wait if you saw this guy the
one on the left is two weeks ago is that
right oh no probably way before oh okay
but here's I'm saying if you saw this
guy walking around and someone told you
is Kim jong-eun you don't have a photo
of them Kim Jin and you know like
everybody hold on let me just pull up a
picture of you real quick so I can
compare me right you smile for me
smile wider please your teeth yes I
don't think that's you know but this is
why the body double thing works because
the average person doesn't have a video
right they see it and their brain fills
in the gaps like that makes us like that
Hillary picture right right but not all
somebody that it's Hillary the then
that's in their brain and suddenly they
can't if even if it isn't heard they're
like yeah that's her and people people
were actually arguing that it was her
but she got plastic surgery yeah so
swear to god yeah they were like it is
her she just got a facelift and it's
like and then like a couple weeks later
she popped up again and she looks normal
it's like maybe that just wasn't her
like rich powerful politicians have body
doubles or maybe she just didn't sleep
very well the night before see what
people don't realize is that we actually
have a whole studio double we've
actually built it into an entire state
so the address so people have been
posting my address and they've actually
got it wrong that's the dummy address
where they fake dummies to the clone
studio is yeah and we hired a body
double for Adam for me for Lydia even
even Betsy and bucko the cats yeah so
beaucoup Betsy and bucko
yes so when you come back and look
through the window you'll see what looks
like our show yeah we're actually an
undisclosed location yeah because we
have to that we have to do that okay so
there there's actually something funny
here North Korean defectors say sorry
after false kim jeong-hoon speculation
but so apparently some defectors were
reporting like hey this is happening and
now that it turns out it's not happening
they're like oops yeah do you think they
just really wanted it to happen
I don't know they're like oh maybe our
dreams is this a former calf or near a
former senior North Korean diplomat has
apologized for saying Kim jong-un was
probably so ill he could not stand days
before he emerged on state media smoking
and walking briskly and an event
attended by hundreds of officials I mean
this photo looks like him I gotta be
honest yeah that right there can you
zoom in on that can't no no but that
does kind of look like him but at the
same time his eyes look a little
different his teeth do look different
here like theirs they do I can see a gap
from this distance you know someone
looks a little different the funny thing
about this is
if it turns out it's not really kim
jungeun yeah
it proves that all of these people who
thought he was our racist yep all a CNN
the they're experts everybody who said
it's not a conspiracy that's clearly him
where's that
so you think us Koreans all look the
same huh it's a body double all right
and then for some reason maybe to like
pretend like they're proving he's alive
they started shooting South Korea so
this this was a was the story this from
a second North Korea's Kim did not have
surgery South says s shots fired at DMZ
so apparently they shouted them and
they're like wait wait okay you're alive
you're alive right right yeah maybe
that's what they're trying to argue like
them but he ordered us to shoot at you
really what is this the government
official decline of ride reasons but
said speculative reports that Kim had an
operation citing some differences in his
leg movements were untrue you know a man
leg movements what we're do that comes
you see a story for everybody yeah you
know TMZ and admittedly like when I saw
the news like I couldn't ignore it
everybody got rope didn't TMZ start this
whole thing no oh I thought they were
the port on it no CNN said he was like
missing him he was missing or listening
yeah he was missing now he was gone so
you know that the the big concern is it
might destabilize the region that's what
I was really expecting kind of going
back to that we were just talk about the
politics the really scary thing really
annoying thing for me is that Donald
Trump said something positive about Kim
Jong Un's and he gets rag dragged for it
and I'm like dude do these people
understand what tact is they accused
they accuse the president of having none
and then he tries to have some they say
how dare you yeah dude he doesn't give
you the time of day but he's giving this
man the time of day because he's trying
to avoid a nuclear war right because
China has their back yeah yeah I'm not
just about the man to do it's the
stupidest thing yeah I agree
like I can sit here and rag on Trump for
the missile strike in Syria the Yemen
stuff Saudi Arabia stuff all day night I
do it a lot and bring it up it's like a
main point but North Korea thing was not
a bad thing trying to talk people down
and bring them into the fold is a good
thing I mean even if he was able to get
Iran to do it would be a maze
so you've got this rogue state that's
like we're building nukes we're gonna
blow stuff up you know you want free
stuff if you can convince them to
normalize trade and just become like a
regular trade for their country huh then
good war averted right instead they're
trying to sink the ship like every step
of the way for Trump like he's flying
this plane and they'd rather to the
plane going to the ocean yeah well I
don't know what's gonna happen with this
but I'll tell you what there's a
possibility in my maíam it's not him
you've got other people saying the same
thing it could just be that he's been
out of the media so long they got
desperate they sent somebody out this
this photo from the Guardian this one
does look like Kim Jong the other photos
are weird the other photos are really
weird maybe it's just really bad angles
yeah teeth look different though you
know yeah gets me
yeah the to line you can't change it
that fast in the ears the flat yeah
they're not out like I don't know you
guys should be getting older and voters
so some of the photos are new though so
mmm I don't know man they say Daily NK
is seoul-based news outlets or PSA's
inside North Korea had reported in April
that Kim was recovering from a
cardiovascular procedure you know you
know it could be maybe he is recovering
and then maybe it's in a body double to
like dispel rumors that he died yeah
because he was strong enough I think
he's just playing video games
yeah he's lazy it's gonna be fun you
know it's funny there's probably some
like eleven-year-old playing like
fortnight yeah against him uh-huh
could you imagine like him sitting there
just like all Angry playing against some
kid gets beat he's like all right like
yelling and banging on stuff sounds like
a South Park episode yeah it's probably
playing against Cartman I wonder what
he's I want right so I what I heard um
I've heard this from some people who
have meant like some journalists who
have been to North Korean stuff mm-hmm
that he was raised he was educated in
the West and he's very much a fan of
like Western things that's why Dennis
Rodman was able to go in and bring the
Weisse people there and so I really
wonder what his goal is like maybe he's
surrounded by these military leaders who
are like the status quo must be
maintained okay but what is it secret
he's like I want to be part of the world
I don't know I don't I'm saying he does
but what's the worst thing for these
people why are they so resistant to it
yeah I don't get like isn't there
something to deal you could negotiate
with them or it's like we will guarantee
that you maintain your wealth status and
administrative control but
we normalized trade we open things up we
bring in more resources I guess the
problem is the the the conflict like
they shoot they fire nukes so we're like
we're not gonna give you stuff you're
gonna keep doing this
yeah so the only option is to get rid of
them like to just depose them but
they're not gonna leave so we're at a
stalemate it's too bad we got tons of
deep-dish pizza that Kim jong-kook could
beat and he looks like a guy who would
like some pizza he does yeah Kim you you
unify the peninsula and give up your
dictatorial powers you love all the
pizza in the world you know there's in
South Korea they have a Chicago pizza
restaurant do they really yeah they have
a thing called like it's called like
black pizza or something I'm sorry what
black pizza go ahead it's got like a
black ink squid ink sauce okay yeah so
I'm like well maybe I'm wrong I remember
seeing it that sounds disgusting no you
can't taste it
yeah I'm still disc it's just like it's
just like but but it's called thing I'm
good a Chicago pizza and it's in I can't
watch camera what district it's in yeah
no thanks but uh yeah it could be all
yours Kim command walking and getting
that big old deep dish you never had to
be shave you wish yard Nair on it really
think do you really think he watches our
show I bet I wouldn't be surprised he's
a deep dish though like just because
people people look at North Korea and
they think everyone there because
they're all starving he is now that
dudes fat for a reason yeah he probably
gets ice cream Italian ice cream you
know gelato made on the spot then
overnight it in a cooler with dry ice to
this you know mansion in North Korea
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you